Miracle co-starring of top creators
Illumination Peace Project Climax 4
Beware of Fire
Katsuhiro Otomo Eiichi Gohara
Tsukumon Osamu Morita and Keisuke Kishi
Gambo & Hiroaki Katsuhito Ishii
Yoshiyuki Sadamoto
Weapons Farewell to Katoki Hajime Katsuhiro Otomo
Tatsuyuki Tanaka
And
5  How will the second work appear?
Glass Hopper Manufacture Goichi Suda
Frispies Yohei Kataoka
Collaboration by top creators realized
Skin Yume Ranko's longest day Dominate the
monthly parking lot Ranko, the only daughter of the conglomerate Tsukigoku Enterprise
The night is a hit that assassinates a given target.
Ranko and her best friend are also good, and
a day without the magic of a hostile organization to them.
High-speed effects action.
Escape from the devil's hands sneaking up and aim for the goal
A unique stage with the image of modern Japan
And the approaching huge enemy
Anime part is a tanto of Kamikaze videos
Various productions
mix various elements that symbolize modern Japan
Top creators record two exclusives for the contemporary Japanese kill
theater movie short peace and PlayStation 3
on one disc
short peace The longest day of Ranko Tsukigoku
Scheduled to be released on January 16, 2014
For more information, please visit the official website.